okay I'll warn you guys beforehand this
is going to be a very boring episode
simply because I still left some boring
stuff to do like adding the borders of
the paths over here and doing stuff with
that and since I promised and I'm going
to keep that promise that I would keep
this series and uncut series with
commentary of me doing everything that
involves me building a roller coaster in
roller coaster tycoon 3 I'm not going to
leave this out and I'm actually going to
share some sample or share some thoughts
and things but I can't promise that this
episode will be that useful it's
probably going to be very stupid simply
because I'm going to have to do some
things that you simply have to do when
you're building coasters but this is
these are just some of those things that
are very boring and even somewhat time
consuming to do so yeah that's the
reason why I might be somewhat quiet in
this episode simply because this is just
some boring stuff so I just kind of want
to finish this around get around doing
this and then move on to some fun stuff
again because we all love the fun stuff
and we don't like their non fun stuff
obviously now first of all as you can
see I am doing this terraforming [ __ ]
basically because I kind of want to
create an area largely not so that I can
actually make this wide path but I don't
want to have this little Hill going down
here and don't worry about this straight
cliff face stuff over here because that
doesn't really matter I'm gonna put like
trees or buildings or whatever I'm gonna
put there anyway so I'm just gonna make
this a little bit bigger so I have some
room to work with I might also do some
buildings in the end but not entirely
sure about that simply because it's very
time consuming again and it's not very
it's not a very generic thing
I'll cover at least one or two buildings
though just to show you guys how I do
that stuff and just to have some nice
scenery around it okay now it's already
bugging but that's that's not too much
of a problem and yeah I'm just gonna
smooth this out simply because I have
OCD you don't necessarily have to do
this I especially if you place buildings
over here it doesn't really matter what
the ground looks like but I just like
the fact that it's a bit more smooth now
because I might as well play some trees
or stuff like that over
here and then I kind of don't want to
have that weird cliff face mmm that
should be just about enough space for my
path but still I'm not too sure about it
so I'm just gonna extend it a bit that
should do and don't worry about this
thing being too and smooth or something
it's not that important so I'm just
gonna continue it over here as well do
make sure that you have enough room
though because you always need to be
well a bit more careful with this
because it's better to have a surface
that's too large than having one that's
too small and then noticing it later on
and realizing that you don't have you
know space to build what you want it to
build mmm this should do for the moment
yeah so it's time for all the boring
cover path stuff on the sides I'm not
entirely sure whether I want to add
sidewalks to this though so mmm I have
no clue actually what to do with that
but I should have enough space it's kind
of going down over here but that's not
too much of a problem as long as they
add a sidewalk that's not conforming it
shouldn't do anything really okay so I'm
just gonna get the same border a little
just gonna get the same borders always
make sure that when you place borders
you place the same borders and sit on
both sides it'll be weird to have
different borders and stuff that is
unless you have different sidewalks as
well in that case it wouldn't really
matter too much but especially in this
case where I kind of want to have the
same things everywhere I don't want to
have yeah because I already made a
mistake here I can Wow I should have
realized that earlier on I'm using a
different color isn't that smart okay
I'm just gonna take that for offset
things that I used this color perhaps
did I it might actually be right though
I'm just gonna test it oh it was
actually right it just looked different
that's very very funny should be an
optical illusion I guess let's see is it
actually the same Wow
I'm getting really tricked in you
yeah it's actually the same wow it just
kind of looks different
due to the surroundings and stuff
interesting didn't expect to see a color
optical illusion in this game hmm I kind
of went to demonstrate that but I
shouldn't do that this isn't optical
illusions to game I'm not gonna do stuff
like that but it must be possible with
more things I just had an idea
a stupid idea Silva Rhett creates
optical illusions in rollercoaster
tycoon 3 I should actually give that a
shot when I'm bored now then hmm
see that's the problem with stuff like
this you don't have five or six or seven
curves so you always need to kind of
work with diagonals and I messed that
one up
mmm still not really sure if I want to
add a sidewalk over here I might just go
for it but then on the other hand I
don't know if that really makes sense to
be fair mm-hm I think you're not I think
I have an idea but before I move on to
anything I kind of do want to make this
straight simply because maybe I'm going
to use some conforming stuff and I don't
want that to happen so it's gonna make
that straight now it should be okay kind
of but not entirely mmm terraforming is
really annoying in roller coaster tycoon
3 one of my biggest hopes is actually
that in roller coaster I can fall for
what rollercoaster tycoon world they're
actually gonna fix the terraforming
engine and make it somewhat more easy to
work with and less annoying because in
rollerCoaster Tycoon 3 it can just be a
[ __ ] sometimes please like this why do
I keep lowering that Wow
I'm such an idiot okay this time around
I'm not even going to pay attention to
those little edges screw it just gonna
terraform it like this
and it's good and we're good to go good
now let's get Bryan Chaz beautiful walls
again
hmm very strange I don't even have a
calling yet I feel like my nose is
somewhat stuffy hey didn't when that
happens hmm yeah I kinda want to yeah
make it about two tiles wide everywhere
and once again two titles I don't know
if I've actually set this before but two
tiles wide on diagonal means two and a
half times why to make it look just as
wide as you can see the well actually no
for every square that you have on a
diagonal you need to add another half a
square now this might not make sense but
I'm actually gonna explain it why why I
have no clue where I'm actually gonna
explain it if you have a one one tile
white path and you're going to turn it
into a diagonal path then you're not
gonna want to do this because as you see
it looks like it's more narrow now even
though there's still a one tile
difference so what I usually do is I add
half a tile for stuff like that for
every year half a tile that it gets
wider I'm also adding half a tile and
I'll explain that later on but basically
if you do this at that one hole thingy
and then at the diagonals it's gonna
look just about as wide as the straight
path it's not exactly the same of course
but it comes pretty close and the same
works in well a similar fashion with two
wide paths where I usually just add one
square because it's too wide I'm gonna
add another square at that another half
thing and then do the diagonals like I
just did with my paths and then you
should be good to go like come on let's
add those diagonals and her I shouldn't
mess it up and there you have it that's
basically how I do most of my paths now
I just realized
that it's actually not like that I think
no it isn't oops I think I just terribly
messed up its where every square that
you place horizontally you need to add
half an edge in the diagonal thing so
yeah that works way better that's
actually the way it works so if you have
a one time wide path you need to add
half a wall so half a tile war so this
little thing and then if it's too wide
that means two times half of war so an
entire one and if it's three wide it's
going to be one and a half at cetera so
that's basically that now it's a shame
that you can't remove custom scenery
with the well removing tool so now I
need to do it manually
piece by piece that's very annoying
whereas we have in-game scenery you can
just select an area where you want to
delete the scenery and then I'll
automatically delete everything okay so
that was that just a little off-topic
thing but I thought I'd share that and
let's see okay so actually pretty funny
now I need to use it right away
so we have a two tile wide path so I
should place the thing over here yeah
that works and once again two tiles wide
so I should place it over there yeah
there we go now of course as if you do
this more often you're getting better at
it and you won't have to really trace
everything and you'll just instantly see
why you have to place the borders but
still it's a very handy trick and now
this is gonna be it's gonna be a bit
tricky simply because mmm I don't want
to keep it three wide so kind of want to
have this mmm this is gonna be actually
really hard
but I feel like this would be the way to
go yeah but this is just a different
thing because the site walk disappears
there and we also go down there but that
shouldn't pose too much of a problem
honestly and let me get that half piece
and a diagonal piece beautiful
um though I must say I'm not entirely
sure about doing this I think I have an
idea
I'm just gonna remove this so don't need
that I am going to go to this finger and
but the same border on the other side
so where is CTRs paths and get those
straight thingies actually no I always
like to play I always like to place the
curves first simply because they're
harder to do so half a tile extra and
place it there and once again here move
it half a tile and place it there there
we go
beautiful and to halftone on pieces
should do the trick exactly like that
and it even works for curves we don't go
in the same direction so where you have
a large curved made out of two straight
two diagonal pieces just move it half a
tile and like that it's not thinking for
me no it's not that's actually a good
thing
thank you thing and also the same goes
for the other side and move it half tile
and place it there know for this middle
middle what middle part I feel like mm
okay now I need two half pieces for that
mm-hmm I like how I just became German
for a second I don't know why I I brain
fight way too often I'm just gonna do
this with some half parts because my OCD
doesn't like seeing things that aren't
smooth and for the time being I'm just
gonna place the curbs over here don't
worry if you want to place buildings
over here some time sooner or later you
can always do that but I always like to
place the curbs first just amp that out
of the way okay nice
and once again I didn't call for tile
though and I feel that at this point
it's gonna be safe to remove that
sidewalk again also we're going up the
hill so might as well mmm
though do I want this thing to be four
tiles wide I probably wouldn't want that
honestly hmm so I kind of want to kind
of want the border to go around over
there and do some stuff I guess you know
I'm just gonna try that so it's gonna
come over here and then the sidewalk is
gonna disappear okay that should work I
think I've covered all of the curves now
yeah all of the curves that I need it
and just then I always do the diagonals
and then I do the straight parts that's
just the way I work though it's not
something that I would force upon you
but it's just a way that I find him nice
to work with okay that's very good and
see this is why I talked about this is
kind of the boring stuff that's probably
also why I keep these episodes a bit
longer what happened to this thing damn
it how do I not see that before but yeah
that's basically why I want to keep this
episode these episodes longer as well
simply because you know I don't want to
cover boring stuff for loads of episodes
I'm just gonna do more boring stuff in
an episode just to keep the content
somewhat ah decent level I guess hmm now
it's time for conforming things but
first I kind of want a and the straight
pieces here though I might as well use
conforming pieces for that so I'm just
gonna go to trees with every set and
I've probably set this before but I
can't stress this you know if always if
it if it does have conforming pieces
they're always in trees for some reason
it's not the the importer doesn't force
you to put it in trees I know why people
always do that but for some reason it's
just become a general custom scenery
creative
to put conforming pieces in trees but
foliage I should say here rather I don't
even know what this thing is called but
it's probably foliage or something like
that but basically yeah that menu where
you get the flower isn't such just
realized this is no this is no this is a
big fat nope it's not wide enough
honestly so get out of the way you you
messed up I'm just gonna mmm I think I
have no idea I'm just gonna go along
with sight walk like that and end it
there yeah that's good then I'll have to
get that sight walk again for that one
little piece but whatever it's not too
much of a problem honestly now this is
this has turned into a weird squiggly
path kind of weird don't want to take
any air shots of that this is not how I
kind of really wanted it to come out you
shouldn't let your path six are too much
especially if they're as wide as this
one but oh well I just like the entire
idea of having that squiggly stuff going
on and the little trees and the coaster
and all that
still not want the sidewalk over there
no I don't think I'm like them oops
I don't want to do that either because
that looks ugly and I'm just gonna
finish all of the borders in this path
in this pot in this pot so kind of want
to finish this up as well this doesn't
have to be s wide also I'm gonna remove
this lamp I don't want all my lamps to
be in the same side only if your path is
really wide I would suggest to put lamps
on both sides but if if your path is
more narrow like this I would suggest
putting like I don't know one lamp over
there and then another one here and then
one over there at cetera okay whereas if
you have a white path for example you
can place them in a parallel line like I
would for example yeah I would probably
like to place a lamp over here and when
over here I went over there simply
because then you'll get lamps on both
sides but once again I think that only
really works for wide paths and roads
now this is a place where I wanted to
create a restaurant so I'm gonna stop
right there but I do want to continue
towards the entrance area where there is
still in game path which I need to fix
soon and once again at this point the
terraforming stuff that I left on the
ground really helps it's a sort of
guideline to see where you need to go
and I think I need just a half piece
yeah that should do what died you can
also die ignores again maybe it's that
maybe it's the problem that I'm
recording during my vacation and I'm
just like chill out everyday and then oh
wait I need to record a roller coaster
in three as well
well let's just do that real quick and
it's probably also because I've kind of
lost interest in this whole path thing I
just want to move on with fun stuff once
again me and my stupid promises that I
always make and probably shouldn't make
is that nice no that's pretty nice
three-wide should do just a little
entrance part and yeah don't worry I'm
gonna remove that in-game stuff and as
soon as possible because it definitely
hurts my eyes no I think I've done all
the conforming stuff so it's time to
move on to the walls section again
because this set doesn't have conforming
large curves don't know why but many
sets don't do that they only have
conforming pieces for a few of the most
important parts of the set so the
straight part and the diagonal parts and
the half parts and stuff like that but
not actually for the big curves like
this one speaking of big this is
probably too big I should move it like
that yeah that works too then I can
always play something cool in the middle
of that square sort of thing and I might
play some rides and stuff over here but
I think I'm gonna continue with the
curbs anyway and in the past I would
have definitely spammed sidewalks
everywhere and I'm not doing that these
days on purpose simply because - don't
do that I think you don't see sidewalks
everywhere but it does look pretty fancy
so if you want to play sidewalks
everywhere go ahead and be my guest but
I've kind of stopped caring about that
same goes for a grand shrubbery I used
to spam that everywhere until at some
point I realized it doesn't necessarily
make your ride much better quality over
quantity is what I'd say in both cases
do you want like that hmm probably don't
but I'm still gonna do it
I think yeah I'm just gonna go for it
it's probably better to have a path
that's too wide than having a path
that's too narrow and if your path is
too wide you can always make it look
less wide by turning planters with large
trees in them stuff like that or ending
things in the middle like little well
planters with benches or stuff like that
I mean large parts so very handy for
making your path for making your Park
look nice and open and stuff but you
don't want it to look empty and as soon
as you add many whites wide paths you'll
take the risk that Europe Park is going
to look very empty basically like in a
desert ish way it's gonna make sure that
you have less trees and attractions
going on and I always like to have more
trees and attractions and paths so yeah
I'd say be careful with that mmm how
wide I want it to be you know I guess so
this the squiggly squiggly line curve
here is kind of weird
oh well
if your path has a very weird shape you
don't necessarily have to worry about it
anyway because nobody's really going to
notice if you look at some maps of parks
in real life you're gonna be like whoa
those paths are very weird but only from
an aerial perspective will you really
see the weirdness of the paths so you're
most likely you most likely won't really
notice it it doesn't even look that bad
like this I'm especially with trees
around it it's not gonna be that
terrible it's also something to keep in
mind don't worry about your rides or
coasters looking terrible when you're
building them because when you're adding
finishing touches and trees and stuff
like that in the end it's gonna look a
lot better how even editing can make
your coaster look a lot better in the
end and some good old camera angles
because right definitely usually looks
less good from an aerial perspective
than it does from the side as you can
see and especially with the advanced
camera with all the nice options that
you have in it the coaster is definitely
going to look a lot better than you
think it would now is this no that's not
how wide I want it to be it should be
wider okay so I'm just gonna take a
couple more diagonals and I kind of need
to hurry up because this episode is
already taking quite a while very nice
oh hell this is it this is also gonna be
terrible to render and Wow all of these
curbs and the next episode is not going
to be much better I hope that often
these two episodes I can move on to
foliage and buildings and stuff like
that
come on mate it's not how I want it to
be yeah pretty much
now I do want to add something else over
here really no though I want to add
something something special but it's not
even finished so I might do that later
on mmm but I do want to add a little war
though before I forget about it so I
should remember that I want to add
something special there I'm just gonna
build that little war don't know exactly
what this is supposed to be but I can
always turn it into a nice little
Bulevar is something with palm trees and
stuff in before people start complaining
about palm trees and yes I am NOT a huge
fan of generic coasters with the
tropical with a tropical theme simply
because it's so overused and overdone
it's pretty much the big room house with
the roller coaster tycoon 3 community
but yeah I'm just gonna go for it anyway
because in some cases I actually really
like how it turns out and despite the
fact that it's overused and probably
overdone as well not many people do it
these days for some reason and any
coaster with any theme can be good you
should enjoyed your coaster or a project
for that matter on what theme it is but
rather on the way it's executed because
someone can literally take a terrible
theme and turn it into an amazing
coaster I remember when I made well I'm
not referring to one of my coasters
because that one is absolutely terrible
but I remember when I made a coaster
called what was it called again
cranberry twirl it was absolutely
ridiculous it was terrible it's the
worst thing ever and then some people
went ahead and they were like mmm we
were going to make a sequel to that it's
gonna be called blueberry yum-yum and
they're still working on it
it might actually be turned into oh wait
I shouldn't talk about that but yeah
blueberry yum-yum anyway and it's
actually one of my favourite coasters in
that sense because it's so crazy it's
got a ridiculous theme but it's so well
and it's got an awesome color scheme and
the theme is just amazing so love it
when people just take funny and
unserious ideas and turn them into great
coasters I mean and sevens also done
that before when he made parodies of
certain coasters or how even people in
the rct3 community so that's pretty cool
I mean it's a game after all as much as
some people take it serious in in the
sense that people spend so much time on
it and have contests and everything it's
still a game and having fun is still the
number one priority so yeah I definitely
like that aspect about things and just
people trying funny ideas but basically
I don't know I can't remember how he got
here from tropical-themed oh wait yeah
right that even a tropical coast it can
look good but that was not even my main
point my main point was basically that
this is simply a tutorial series in
which I teach how to do certain stuff
hopefully and the tropical theme is just
because it's so generic and you can
basically you don't have even have to
add any real scenery to it anyway that
it's a good thing to start off with for
a tutorial because yeah it's easy to
learn and also easy to teach so that's
why is this actually a good idea to do
because you know I'm just gonna go for
it but the only problem that I have with
this is that I think it doesn't have any
real columns like columns without a
thing on it I'm just gonna have to do it
like this then oh well it's not too much
of a problem but I wish that it actually
it was actually like I don't know for a
chai so he didn't have so he wouldn't
have to do this
how am i I need to even stack three of
these things not sure if that's such a
great idea but it's just that the
texture and the shape of this thing in
general I just don't like it so much
this is actually going to be fun with
planters and lights and all that cool
stuff
that's why I like about building these
kinds of things oh well that's about it
for today and we've got loads of boring
stuff done and I've been talking about
loads of stuff that I shouldn't have
talked about but whatever thank you for
watching and till see you in the next
episode in which I'm actually going to
do some other boring so